katar and its role in the arab world an
interview with the prime minister of
Qatar Hamad bin Jassim Al Thani Miley
your excellency for the past couple of
years Qatar has made various investments
across Europe including in Germany
what's the motivation behind them and
what are the areas here that Qatar is
looking to invest in might feel about my
feel like thank you as far as our
investments are concerned globally as
well as in Germany we've invested in a
range of large companies our goal is to
increase our country's wealth for future
generations anything that's left over
after we've paid for domestic
development projects is invested
internationally well is that them that
will ensure money keeps coming in as oil
and gas revenues decline according to
the wish of His Highness Prince Hamid
and the crown prince this is a policy
we've been pursuing for five years now
unsuccessfully I'm Artemus who would any
other was soon worried I had our
investments yield good returns and at
the same time we're gaining valuable
experiences in global markets and then
Fattah - what could I do me regarding
global markets Qatar's also invested in
Arab countries especially those involved
in the Arab Spring
specifically in Egypt these investments
have been controversial what's your view
who milah I think it's a bogus
controversy most of the issues that are
being raised are based on rumors
frankly all of the issues are based on
false rumors at whatever level Thalian I
don't believe it's a sin to support
sister states and to invest in an Arab
country this is part of Qatar's plan
to invest in Arab countries such as in
agriculture in Sudan or Morocco Sena
what well I can be selfish here see we
began investing in Egypt years ago
however there were disagreements with
the former government we also invested
in Syria prior to the revolution but I'd
like to emphasize that these kinds of
investments in Arab countries are
necessary they create jobs and above all
we believe that this represents a step
towards regional economic integration
and the spread of wealth in many Arab
countries the debate that's taking place
in Egypt at the moment is political in
nature because none of the issues raised
reflects reality there is no evidence
that we violated any Egyptian laws we
respect the law of the land and we
respect our relationship with Egypt it's
an important country and a strong Egypt
will benefit all Arabs and that's why I
think that it's our duty to support this
country at a time like this you
mentioned your support for regional
neighbors during the Arab Spring Qatar
was among the first countries to come
out in support of the protest movements
in Tunisia Egypt and Libya what's your
take on the situation in these countries
two years on you know revolutions go
through various phases I don't think
these revolutions have reached full
maturity yet they're currently at a
stage in which they're suffering from
exhaustion of wealth and reserves I'm
confident I hope we'll see the formation
of new systems that will bring about an
upswing that will rejuvenate the powers
of these states this day and that the
people and not just a group or a
government will be at the center of this
development and this progress then Mia
will head of the rocky wall a sefa
oh ho Coomer they had that there now
Ahava no badness
since the upheavals in the Arab world
the role of some countries in the Arab
League has diminished at the same time
the role of Qatar and Saudi Arabia in
the Arab League has increased some
people even say the Gulf states are
taking a leadership role what do you
think they are the hello year general
Arabiya Gifford Lyla quarter an ahmadi
that semi-happy I wouldn't want to call
it leadership you know that some
countries in the Arab world are going
through changes others have internal
problems others still have kept their
traditional roles within the Arab League
the Gulf Cooperation Council in general
and Qatar in particular and I can speak
only for Qatar have no intention of
claiming a leadership role in the league
this is not true and it wouldn't be
possible either but the question remains
what can we do to encourage cooperation
between member countries and to create
an effective system within the league
but serves all Member States not just
Qatar this is something we're trying to
do I believe there's a common Arab
awareness at every level at the
governmental level as well as at the
level of the Arab League we need to use
this awareness to encourage Arab
cooperation Alina Nestor below then why
literally me Larabee you Shakira
the league has denied reports of the
possible resignation of the Syrian
special envoy Lakhdar Brahimi how do you
see his mission do you still support it
and is it still having an impact
what's important to note is that the
issue here is not Arab or international
support what's much more important is
whether the Syrian regime is prepared to
find a political solution to the
conflict or if it's just trying to bide
its time throughout the mission of
Lakhdar Brahimi who we trust and whose
mission we support the Syrian government
never
offered anything concrete just empty
promises that is a waste of time
while the killing of innocent people in
Syria continues unfortunately nothing
has changed so far and that's why we
need to evaluate what we've learned so
far and prepare the mission for the next
phase hey Dennis 30ml Phil Fatah and
Padma are the last Arab summit you
supported the idea of supplying weapons
to the Syrian opposition has Qatar
started supporting the Syrian opposition
with weapons the Hamada the Soviet no
man see I do this is a decision of
national sovereignty but the Arab League
and the Arab summit have agreed to this
idea regardless of whether there was
support before or not what's important
is the result what's important is that
we stop the bloodshed in Syria I believe
a political solution is only possible
when the two powers in Syria achieve a
certain balance unfortunately the
government is being supported by some
other actors instead of us seeking a
common solution well so you cannot say
one party can be supported with weapons
while the other only gets rhetoric
practical support is needed to lead Aven
she Emily Lee Heather in FM does that
mean Qatar has already decided to
support the opposition with weapons I'm
speaking in general terms I'm not
speaking about Qatar specifically given
a farm a good man mewho
what's your position on the role of
Islamist groups within the Syrian
opposition especially after the al-nusra
front last week acknowledged its ties to
al-qaeda and them Qaeda peyman alahi
part of the problem is that the delay in
finding a solution is leading to
radicalization
we know that Syrian society is like a
mosaic its multi-ethnic and
which is why no one group can claim
leadership Syria must be for all Syrians
Muslims Christians Druze Kurds and for
all other groups this is the foundation
for support and the basis for Syria's
future in the past Syria wasn't governed
for all its people in a way Syria was a
cover for terrorism we know where the
terror came from and who was behind it
but we didn't want to talk about it now
because it wasn't made into an issue at
the time and there's no point in putting
it on the agenda now feminine may even
have shame but longer we wait the more
serious the conflict in Syria will be I
think we already bear responsibility
fishery AHA deal had and I had another
Haman Masoli attack one question about
Lebanon the Doha conference helped guide
Lebanon's political parties to a
consensus now a new government is being
formed and Saudi Arabia is playing a
special role in that process has Qatar's
role in Lebanon diminished no true
father of the year we and our brothers
in Saudi Arabia understand the situation
some people feel that we in competition
with Saudi Arabia but that is not true
we always say that Saudi Arabia is the
backbone of the Gulf Cooperation Council
and we support whatever role Saudi
Arabia takes Saudi Arabia is taking a
leading role in Lebanon and we support
that the Doha Conference also supported
that Qatar is not seeking a dominant
role anywhere that is not our goal our
goal is a stable Arab world developed in
all areas an Arab world which rejects
violence and puts the focus on work
education and health care
our goal is peace across the entire
region there must also be peace with
Israel and the legitimate rights of the
Palestinians should be restored we
should live in peace and this is also
what the Arab initiative wanted we do
not seek leadership but peace and
stability in the Arab world there was a
time when some Arab countries were not
bold enough now we're seeing the Arab
Spring bring change to some regimes the
rules of play in the region have changed
radically
Elaraby you are a failure at the lab
ferrara Nara will be shaken Kabir chitin
not your excellency thank you very much
for your time and for this interview a
football that happens